when you have so many people watching
you
and you you know do you
know that do you take that in do you
remove ego
how do you like handle it all
i honestly took a real long break for
myself and by real long and internet
world that's about
a year of not consistently uploading on
youtube and i really took that to take a
step back
and evolve and
be a human being and allow myself to
move through a
you know more difficult time in my life
on my own and not you know go live but
go live and so that's what i really
needed and to
not realizing that i was i was setting
an example for some other young kids
that said you know i really needed to
put my phone down and i didn't do that
until you did and i'm
grateful to have ever been that but
that's my encouragement to everyone of
every age
is to put that phone down sometimes and
go live out in the real world because
sometimes your feed
can construct a reality that isn't
actually your truth and you start
believing it and it messes with your
your inner dialogue or your inner
beliefs so i'm a firm believer
in you know taking that break and
reconnecting with yourself
you're ever changing ever evolving so go
discover something new that you might be
into and
and have never tried before so that's
how i keep myself grounded that
family faith and friendships um i think
this might need to be like a new hashtag
and a t-shirt
is you just said uh don't go live
go live they look the same in writing
so we'll have to work on that but one
will be italicized or something
yes exactly okay so sorry um before we
finish
i just wanted to also show this gorgeous
makeup that i've been looking at
101 oh my god that's so exciting to see
you hold it
i love this so this is to do different
um colorations and pigments and
will you take us through this palette
real quick though i'm so glad i had
conveniently here
um this is a strap that adds on to the
face mask artist set which is what this
is a bunch of face masks in here
so there's actually an upcycle story
because i want to be able to use your
packaging or reuse your packaging
um is so important because so much
plastic is is created when it comes to
products that
we added two latches on there so you can
add your little gucci strap or other
humble straps
on there and create a purse for yourself
or a lunch box for your kids i love the
step and repeat packaging it really
speaks to me the second i saw it i was
like
oh yeah man that's cool
i love it i love getting inspired by the
way what are these colors and what do
they do may i
ask um this is something i've always
wanted to see in the world and i got to
make it with same one beauty
this is our face mask artist set so i'm
so happy to collab with them on this
this is butt a face that i'm putting on
and someone called me that in middle
school
and now i made a product and we're good
i love
that i love that i i i have a ballet
teacher i was just talking about it
i was like i'm going to find you one day
and haunt your dreams
[Music]
who she used to just embarrass me in
front of the whole class
and then i was like you know what though
if you hadn't done that
i wouldn't be who i am i wouldn't i
wouldn't have
the empathy level maybe so you know what
bring it this that you're playing with
is
my mask artist set so it kind of looks
like paint pots that was the point
if you can be an artist with your makeup
why can't you be one with your mask
different parts of your face have
different needs
so i know double masking is frowned upon
so quadruple masking no one said
anything about
um so these are four different masks
they each do different things this one's
a glow one
um so it's like a brightening one we
have a resting b
face which is relaxing um which one's
this one
this is show face when you want to show
off and face off for
face exfoliation i love
the blush sticks i love the whole line
and i really love
the social media behind it i think that
it's really fresh and beautiful and fun
i know you have that with flour too i
love your flower like
lip and tint so gel blush and cream
blush has a tendency to sort of pick up
everything flawed underneath it and
amplify it and this is not this is
sitting right on top
this is the good quality stuff right
here
yes from a beauty junkie to a chunky oh
no this is incredible
okay well um so glad
personally the reviews are in oh this is
amazing
you're amazing i just really
am behind you cheering you on keep doing
what you're doing
thank you liza um liza's collection one
of one by semois
is available now it's so cool
as a chic